[Music]
my name is roofin lakhs I'm a software
engineer on Google cloud platform and
we're here with our wonderful partners
at Scotiabank to talk about Google Cloud
dataflow streaming and how we auto scale
streaming pipelines and then we will
talk about how Scotiabank uses this
functionality so first a little bit of a
little bit of background on streaming
data flow pipelines as streaming
pipelines in general and why auto
scaling is important so unlike
traditional batch applications where you
just run once and then they're done if
your data later is if late later you
have more data you run it again with you
know larger larger set of inputs right
and more resources streaming pipelines
are always on you start usually start a
string in cluster a stringing pipeline
and just leave it running continuously
but in most cases the incoming load to
this stream pipeline varies over time
often these are daily diurnal variations
so you know and then twelve o'clock at
midnight you have much lower levels of
volume of data coming in then at peak
hours your volume increases and keeps
going up and down throughout the day and
so traditionally what people have had to
do to deal with this is to provision
their streaming pipelines for the peak
load figure out how much at how many
resources do I need to handle the
busiest time of day make sure my stream
pipeline has at least that many
resources sometimes even more because if
anything falls behind you need to
process even faster than that to catch
up and this is a this was this is very
expensive you know you're wasting my
many of the resources throughout most of
the day and one of the things we set out
to solve with data flows streaming auto
scaling so here's a quick agenda for
this talk I'm going to start off with a
quick overview of Apache beam and data
flow and how
execute stripping pipelines I'm gonna
talk a bit about what our primary
signals are for streaming auto-scaling
and how this works today and in our new
upcoming streaming engine which will
replace the current one and then finally
our representative from Scotiabank
will talk about how they are using data
flow and auto scaling to solve their
their problems so here we have a visual
about of a essentially the hello world
of data processing problem so the hello
world of data processing problem that
everybody likes to start with is count
words reading a bunch of reading a bunch
of lines and output how many words you
have so it's a fairly trivial problem
but it's it's the it's the getting
started guide that everybody uses so on
the right this is the code you would
write with the Apache beam API which is
the API to data flow to account words we
this is a stream pipeline so we read
words from a pub sub topic split split
every line into its component words and
here we've decided to window it by five
minutes so our output is every five
minutes how many how many words of each
how many of each unique words did we see
in that last five minutes and then
finally count them and write the data
out now it turns out that even though
this pipeline has one two three four
five steps in it the data flow has and
optimizers that optimizes this into a
smaller number of steps for execution
and what we actually end up with is two
steps separated by separated by actually
the component of this count will we have
to shuffle data around so we can
actually count to count the words
properly and that is the string shuffled
on the Left connecting that the two
steps and it turns out that when it
comes to auto-scaling we can usually
look at these two steps independently
and auto-scale each one separately and
also unlike batch pipeline
is where you you will have steps in a
sequence and usually once that finishes
completely and then when it's done the
next step starts in streaming pipeline
we're data it's constantly streaming
through all steps in the pipeline are
active at the same time so you have two
autos your auto scaling algorithms must
take an account everything in parallel
so how do I turn on auto scaling well
today you turn it on by by passing in a
cuff flag to your pipeline when you
launch it and say auto scaling out
within equals throughput based in the
future we plan for auto scaling to just
be the defaults are always on this is
but until then this is how you turn it
on for stringing pipelines and you can
also specify a max number workers flag
which will give us a ceiling on auto
scaling so if you say not some workers
equals a thousand then we will never
auto scale up above a thousand even if
even if it needs it to keep up with its
input so how how does this work under
the covers so to explain a little bit
about how our dos going works I have to
start off by explaining a little bit
about data flows execution model under
the covers how we take a data flow
program and actually schedule it and run
it on GCE workers and the first the
first thing I have to explain is that in
data flow are underlying runner
everything is done in the context of a
key so all data is really separated into
key value pairs that we then shuffle
around and process if you've done a
group by key or account by key or in
this case account words then the key is
obvious it's the key is just is just the
word you're counting if if you're not
doing any sort of aggregation and it
turns out we still have a key that we
just randomly assigned to all the
elements we take all the keys we then
hat we prefix each one with a hash so we
we take a hexadecimal hash of each key
and
put it at the beginning of every key and
that just which does two things first of
all it smears out the work so if you
have a lot of keys that are very similar
they don't end up together it tends to
spread them out across the hash space
and also gives us a nice way of chopping
this work up so since every key starts
with a 16 character hash we can then
just take ranges of these hashes and I
use that to divide up the work into
multiple charts so here is an example of
stage a we have taken all the keys based
off of an estimate of how large we think
the input is we have divided the key
ranges up into a certain number of
ranges a and started the pipeline so
next we actually start the workers that
will run these these stages and the
stream pipeline so here these little
blue icons are standard GCE icon we
started a number of GC workers and for
each GC worker we take some number of
these key ranges and assign it to that
worker so here we have you know
Kri ter J are signed to this one kxky
are assigned to that worker there are
more workers in between every worker has
some number of key ranges for this dream
pipeline assigned now how does this
actually work on our system today and
this is an exam this is something that
is actually explained either is changing
with the upcoming streaming engine but
the way the current system works is
everything runs on these GCE virtual
machines so every virtual machine that
has a key ranger scientist has
persistent disks attached to it to store
state for that key race so if you're
doing a say a 5-minute activation or an
one hour window degredation you need to
be able to constantly keep track
persistently of what your aggregations
are so far for this window if the worker
crashes and has to restart you don't
want to lose any data so currently we
use persistent disk and a key value
store on top of the persistent disk on
each VM to store this state as I'll
explain later we have a our new
streaming engine moves all of this into
the cloud and so all this work the
boozes off moves off these workers you
also need to shuffle data so pub/sub
pub/sub is a completely undone sorted
source which means i'm counting words
all the words might show up on all the
workers so if i want to take the word
next for instance and count how many
nexts i've seen over the past five
minutes i need to make sure all these
next counts end up on a unique worker so
i can do this count so we have a
streaming shuffle system that moves that
these records around between the workers
so we can do these concept alright so
now that i've talked a little bit about
how things work under the covers let's
move on to auto scaling for a second or
for the rest of rest of my talk in order
to scale a pipeline we need signals we
need something that tells us this
pipeline doesn't have enough workers
attached to it we're not keeping up and
also a signal that gives us an estimate
of how many workers we need in this
pipeline now your pipeline is not
keeping up you have 15 workers I
estimate that with 25 workers you'll be
able to keep up so what are our primary
signals for auto scaling the first one
is backlog is there data coming in if
data is coming in faster than we can
process it then the data is going to
start piling up and form a backlog so if
if this backlog is high and especially
if this backlog keeps growing that's a
sign that we don't have enough workers
and we need to auto scale up the second
one is throughput how fast how fast am I
currently processing the data I'm not
you know maybe I'm currently processing
the data at 10,000 GBS 100,000 QPS or a
million QPS
but then we have to contrast that with
the actual input rate so the input rate
is how fast the data is actually showing
up at my pipeline so if I'm processing
data at a million QPS and my input rate
is 1.2 million QPS clearly I'm not
processing fast enough and the input
rate what is we can always estimate the
input rate by taking the throughput that
we're currently processing data at and
since measuring how fast is our backlog
growing so if I'm processing data at say
10 gigabytes per second but then I can
measure my backlog and say okay but my
backlog keeps growing at a 1 gigabyte
per second a good estimate of your input
rate is 11 gigabytes per second that's
how much you know if I if I was able to
process that my backlog would stop
growing and finally we look at CPU
consumption to understand how much CPU
all these workers are using which is
another important signal for auto
scaling so let's talk for a second about
backlog so here we have cloud pub/sub so
a bunch of a bunch of data coming from
cloud pub/sub into our pipeline presume
and believe there is a publisher out
there that is pushing data into pal
cloud pub/sub and remember we had two
stages in this pipeline stage a and
stage be stage a is the stage that's
pulling data front pops up so the first
thing we want to measure is what is the
backlog for stage a if you're familiar
with Google cloud pub/sub but Google
cloud pub/sub will store a backlog for
you in fact it will store up to seven
days worth of backlog this can happen if
data is getting pushed to pups up and
nobody's pulling from it or if data is
getting pushed to pub/sub and you're
pulling from pub/sub slower than the
publishers are publishing so the first
thing we do for stage a is we we say
okay our source is pub/sub let's ask
google cloud pub/sub what the combat
so we have an internal API that gives us
the backlog it's also available through
staff driver so you can go to staff
drive for yourself and look at the UH
nacked messages metrics and see what the
signal is that we're looking at to know
that the backlog is building up in
pub/sub and faster than we're draining
it but then remember we have a streaming
shuffle between stage a and stage B
stage B is where we produce the final
counts the final windowed counts of for
these words so we need a measure about
the backlog between stage a and B as
well so if we're pulling data from
pub/sub and we're keeping up from pops
up and then we're pushing data to this
next stage to say hey count words and
the next stage can't keep up the backlog
for that next stage will grow as well so
that also means we don't have we don't
have enough workers running to maintain
our pipeline
so the first backlog tells us we
wouldn't have enough worker we don't
have enough workers running to pull from
pub/sub fast enough the second backlog
tells us we don't have enough workers
internally to do all these counts we're
trying to do so in this talk I'm going
to make a few simplifying assumptions to
make the auto scaling algorithm a little
bit simpler so the first assumption is
that every stage couldn't be sized
independently but I can go look at every
stage of my pipeline decide what the
appropriate number of workers is for
that stage and then I can decide based
off of all that how many workers I need
for my entire pipeline you know maybe I
take the max of all those and say that's
how many workers I mean I'm assuming
that that the load is distributed fairly
evenly between workers so if you
remember I said that we put a hash a
prefix on all the keys this actually
does a fairly good job of distributing
load fairly evenly among all workers and
finally in practice we apply smoothing
so as I'll explain in a minute there's
some cost to auto scaling so if you have
a sudden spike that lasts a second you
don't necessarily want your you know
your auto scar through like up down up
up down up down so we apply a smoothing
window which currently is in practice I
believe a two-minute smoothing window so
we have some sort of you know smoother
Auto scanning up and down so what if
this means that auto scaling works
fairly well when you have continuous
variations and load its if if your
problem is you know my load is usually
10 QPS and then once an hour it spikes
to a million QPS for 5 seconds now auto
scaling is gonna take some time to go up
and down for that you know for that for
that spikey so how do we use these
signals to actually decide we need to
auto scale up well when the backlog is
high or when we see the backlog is
growing which is a sure sign that we
don't have enough resources to prosper
on this pipeline we generally start
generating size recommendations and we
have the data flow service and our back
end has a loop that is constantly
generating size recommendations for a
pipeline so what is the size
recommendation well first of all we we
measure the input rate and if you
remember the input rate is the rate
we're currently processing at plus the
rate at which my backlog for the
pipeline is increasing and that's the
estimate of how how fast the data is
really arriving after we've measured the
input rate it turns out we're not quite
done because if my backlog is currently
one terabyte and I upscale until I can
handle the current input rate of data my
backlog will just stay frozen at one
terabyte because I now I have enough
workers to handle if the data is coming
in but not enough workers to drain that
backlog so we then have to add to that
how many workers do I need to consume
that backlog quickly while maintaining
the current input rate that eventually
we will you know drain that backlog on
be at a backlog of zero or close to zero
and at that point all we need is enough
workers to keep up with the input rate
and as I just mentioned we average this
recommendation over a sliding two-minute
window and so we have a little bit of
smoothing on these recommendations so
what do we do when the estimated backlog
is low so how do we decide that we have
too many workers and we can we can now
down scale this job
well I'll divide it into the current
world and the the new streaming engine
world which as which is actually
innovated can be tried now the current
world takes the takes a new
recommendation but actually has to be
very conservative and down scaling and
the reason why is if you remember the
the current architecture attaches
persistent disks to every worker and the
work ski ranges are tied to these
persistent disks empirically we found
that if you get an imbalance so you
start having like 10 persistent this on
this worker and to persistent this on
this worker it actually makes
performance worse because the workers
with a very small number of it's become
a bottleneck for all the other workers
so on the persistent disk architecture
we attempt to only downscale if we can
make sure that all the workers have an
even number of persistent disks which
often means that if we can down scale by
one VM we might hold off and say that'll
create an imbalance we're gonna way that
we can down still buy enough VMs to even
out the Briton disks and only then will
we down scale on a streaming engine
there are our new architecture there are
no persistent disks attached to the VMs
the VMS are stateless so we can download
continuously so as that we can just
monitor the CPU we target see are down
scaling a CPU utilization of 80% so you
do not want to target 100% CPU
utilization because that does not give
you enough wiggle room so often you
might have small spikes that are not
high enough to trigger up scaling and/or
not long enough to trickle up scaling
you want to actually have enough enough
wiggle room
to handle small variations in input so
this is what our worker instance looks
like if in the current world so this is
a GCE VM we run the SDK worker this is
the data flow or a beam code that you
have written so this is a Java or a
Python process that runs the data the
dataflow pipeline there is another
process that runs on this a VM called
that is our streaming engine worker this
is the process that knows how to
interpret the code you've written and
turn it into you know persistent shuffle
and so on and then there are a number of
persistent disks attached attached to
these workers this is the world we're
moving to so the new worlds all of the
GC workers are completely stateless
there is no persistent disk attached to
them which means we can just add more or
tear tear them down as we want there is
less cost associated if less complex we
don't have to detach disks move into
another VM and attach them and we also
do no longer have this restriction of
trying to keep an even number of disks
attached to each worker because there
are no dispatch in this world the
dataflow service and the streaming
engine service both from the cloud and
all the state storage and all the timers
and so on also running the cloud which
as a side note something I forgot to
mention earlier and when I was talking
about streaming signals we actually have
one more streaming signal the way
windowing works and data flow is under
under the covers our streaming engine
has a notion of timers or for every team
we're processing it can set timers at
the end of the current window and when
the window expires all these timers fire
and what the timers fire we say ok the
window is done for this key you know
process of the count and spit it out we
can measure timer backlog so we can
measure that a lot of timers are about
fire what this means practically is our
auto-scaling can see the future in a way
we can detect that hey the input rate is
still steady but we're about to hit the
end of a window and all these timers are
about to fire we better start
auto-scaling now so we don't hit the end
of the window and then somebody start
thrashing and you know wait two minutes
and then start auto-scaling up so this
allows window a window processing to
auto scale much more smoothly by be able
to use timers as part of our one of our
signals and as I said you know no
persistent disk here ages are fluid this
is in beta so you can try this today on
your pipe on your pipeline it is
currently only only launched in beta
right now in two regions so right now US
central one and you are Europe West one
I believe are the two regions where
we've launched us then but in one of
those two regions you can pass in this
experimental flag and it will run it on
the new beta engine and if you have any
issues right this engine please let us
know immediately this is why this is why
things aren't beta so we can shake out
all problems to the surface before we
launch it to GA so there's some cost to
resizing so in the persistent disk world
the cost is you know there's latency
detaching and moving discs around our
reattaching them there's some startup
latency for a virtual machine we have to
pause work while the wall the rebalances
and process you know you had a worker
you have to move some work from another
work to the new one and for all these
reasons after a resizing event you need
a stabilization window because so what
you don't want is a hysteresis problem
where I resize and move work around and
that temporarily slows things down
slightly and that makes me think that
I'm falling more behind so I scale up
more and scale up more you know you can
have a positive feedback loop that goes
out of control so after a resizing event
instead we introduce a stabilization
period to make sure the system can quiet
down after a resize before we
exam it again and decide to resize again
the hope is that our initial estimate on
the resize was accurate so we won't have
to resize again quickly but if we do we
need to wait slightly longer before
doing so
and finally low CPU with high backlog
there are cases in which the backlog
keeps going up we start adding more
workers adding more workers and then we
look at the workers and say all these
workers
none of these VMs are using more than
10% CPU all this auto scaling up is not
helping and the reason why could be that
your pipeline is maybe your pipeline is
talking to external service and you're
being throttled so adding more workers
is not helping matters it might making
matters worse because you're just
hammering that external service even
more and it's going to start throttling
you more it could also be due to a bug
in a pipeline maybe your pipeline is
throwing an exception and so that's why
it's not making progress we're not
helping matters by adding more workers
so more workers can throw exceptions in
parallel so for this reason we actually
have a CPU cap if the CPU is too low we
stop upscaling so I mentioned cloud
pub/sub so cloud pops up is natively
supported it's by our streaming engine
and there is an API currently an
internal API that we use to measure the
backlog and the watermark for cloud
pub/sub although this backlog api is
also available via a stack driver you
can go to stack driver and add an old
asan act metric to monitor the backlog
for your pub subtopic the beam SDK also
supports custom sources so if you have a
custom source there are you have to
implement these two methods which allow
you to report what the current backlog
of your custom sources and we can use
that to estimate backlog on the source
and upscale if you if you have a source
that doesn't report those upscaling will
still happen based off our internal
backlog measurement but it will
work as well because we cannot measure
what the back actual backlog on the
sources and pub/sub IO which I already
mentioned our Kafka source and our
Kinesis source support this out of the
box so if you use either Koffler Kinesis
backlog will be measured so in
conclusion I talked about our primary
signals for auto-scaling a bit about how
our Java SDK is supported for
auto-scaling Python streaming was just
currently in beta will be supporting
auto scaling very very soon and the new
streaming engine which is currently in
beta will take our existing auto scaling
and make it work that much better and
now I'm delighted to introduce Roy
Bryant from Scotiabank Scotiabank has
been one of the leaders in the financial
services industry of moving their
processing over to Google cloud platform
especially this type of data processing
and Roy is here to tell us a little bit
about what they've done and how they've
done it
[Applause]
thanks Ruben yeah so I'm going to bring
it up a little bit higher level Rubens
and talking about the details of of how
dataflow works and I'm just going to
talk a bit about the use cases we're
using we're trying to transform the bank
pub/sub and data flow are foundational
to that so I just wanted to talk a bit
about what we're doing a little bit
about Scotia Bank in case you don't know
anything about it the bank's been around
a long time it's a in the top 40 or 25
largest banks in the world depending on
how you measure that it's really
international it was founded in Nova
Scotia long ago and doing trade that
came into the ports so more than half
the business is outside Canada there's
business in 55 countries 23 million
customers which is getting close to the
population of Canada and so we've got a
few challenges in the infrastructure
part of it is we've got it's been around
a long time so we have you know legacy
back-end systems more than 50 years old
we're doing lots of digital banking and
transformation online stuff in many
regions many countries so we want to go
fast there we've also done a lot of
acquisitions so we went over one 10 year
period we acquired 30 banks each with
two data centers we have lots of data
centers as sort of this effort that
consolidate that and rationalize those
stacks so it's we've got some complexity
so the trust and the reputation is
foundational to the business as it is
with the financial services across
financial services and how we handle PII
is key to that so big step is moving the
PII to the cloud and making sure that's
entirely safe and we've got a lot of
stakeholders security and operations as
every large organization does we also
have in addition to legal we've got
internal and external auditing we've got
regulators and we're in 55 countries so
we've got 55 regulators and this and
there's a tension but the velocity for
the digital we want to go
fast and iterate and get features out
the customers moving agile and then we
also have a lot of back-end
infrastructure teams that you know we
care a lot about stability and
reliability and everything we actually
want both both places we want the
digital stuff to be stable and reliable
and we want to bring more velocity to
the to the core banking systems so we're
trying to do that using cloud when we
think about cloud we're thinking about
it more as a method rather than a
destination so we kind of we conflate
cloud as you know moving it to cloud
along with DevOps and C ICD and
test-driven development and all those
all those pieces so we've got two
production systems that are using
pub/sub and dataflow first one I'll talk
about is our log streaming so we've got
pulling in structured and unstructured
data and logs from stock stock driver
from many different sources from all the
projects running and then we publish
those to pub/sub and then use beta flow
to route those to secure it's a cops and
persist them for regulatory purposes
feed it back to ops all that kind of
thing and for this we found it's it
works you know pub/sub in and data flow
will work well and there you know
performant and they give us the
performance we need and we don't really
see any issue with that going forward so
we're happy with it this isn't really
transformational I think the second use
case I think is more interesting because
it's the foundation for how we're
transforming the bank so for this the
problem we're trying to solve is we've
got a lot of different back-end systems
with many data sources so in Canadian
banking we've got over 2000 production
databases all with data in different
formats and different different
representations no agreement on what a
customer is and what a first name of a
customer is and when the count is and so
forth so we're trying to rationalize
that and then so it's a 2000 and Canada
and we're
in 55 countries we're not going to in
place to start
refactoring all our databases it's just
not going to work so what we're doing is
we're using cloud as an opportunity to
to restructure the wave we we do all
this so on ingestion we're transforming
the data into a standard format so we've
got an enterprise data model and the
business glossary that you can define
what exactly is a customer what is the
customers first name and then we map
from local schemas in all the different
data sources we bring that in we map it
to the standard schema see in the you
know say this is the customers first
name this is an account number
all that bring the data all into one
place that does a bunch of things one is
that we can now it opens up it opens the
door for doing analytics and you can do
analytics across you know many data
sources all the performance and so forth
from that the other thing is that it
puts a cache of the data in cloud so
we've got banks you know we do a bunch
of Canadian banking and we've got you
know you're using your handset and
you're doing online banking and then
we've got backends in Toronto we've got
backends in Chile
everything's far apart so what we're
doing is we're taking a cache of things
in cloud so you can hit hit we can put
the computer close to the to the data so
so we're using this that we're calling
is the event layer this event layer
there's the two pieces that pub/sub and
dataflow are key in one is the ingesting
ingest in the data into the common
format so for here we're streaming from
back-end systems in its mq cobol
copybook whatever down there transform
that stream that up into cloud it comes
into pub/sub and then we use dataflow so
on ingestion we're transforming it to
the standard schema we're also using DLP
and and kms and in creating tokenizing
the data so we've got it in flight comes
in and then in data flow called DLP on
the fly as it flows through
tokenize that landed in spanner now it's
all encrypted safe there and then we
just and then we you know lockdown riad
notification separately so so there's
the standard format getting the cache
the other piece is moving to
event-driven so we're taking events that
can be you know infrastructure events or
security or operations also just changes
in back-end data we're detecting that
you know raising an event for that or a
transaction comes in and then we're
persisting the transactions so now
instead of the application needing to
figure out how to talk to you know many
back-end systems and having the business
logic in the application and in the
backend systems and the api's and api's
call other api's and it's really hard to
tell what the business logic is so
instead about changing it to the the
event flow and then that gives us all
the data in the cloud and then when we
start looking forward we can see what
are the changes in the backend system so
if we can understand the data and we've
we built up the history of exactly how
the data changes on events we can start
you know reversing out and making sure
that we've got the you know the business
logic right so if we're trying to
replace a back-end system we can run it
again you know we've got some code that
we assert works the same way you can run
it through all the you know the last
year's transactions and see if you get
the same answer every time so and then
the and then for the api's so we don't
get we're trying to break that we don't
want these all these layered api's on
the backend systems so what we do is we
we bring the data into the event layer
then you can either so applications can
either subscribe to the stream of events
and see transactions that way or can
query the storage or we also expose it
through API so we have a data as a
service API that that lets you access
API driven do the queries against the
data and then we have a bank as an API
level above that with Bank concepts you
can say you know what are the accounts
that this
customer has and then it'll use the data
API you can do the queries give a
structured way to to get out that so
what we've accomplished so we have these
these couple of things in production and
we've used and as I said the
transformation to standardize data and
event-driven is really foundational to
our strategy for transforming the bank
and then pops up and data flow or our
foundational to the implementation of
that strategy and we've been really
happy with you know the performance the
cost reliability of the systems they've
all worked really well in production the
other factor we considered in choosing
Google to do this is there's a really
strong relationship a collaborative
relationship we've got a lot of
engineering support so this is gone
really well thank you
[Music]